Hi, it's Ira Glass. Leave a message.
你好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。请留言。
Hey Ira. It's Nancy. I'm calling you from the studio and I'm going to hang up and try you back. Bye. [PHONE RINGING]
嘿，艾拉。我是南希。我从演播室给你打电话，我打算挂断后再打给你。再见。[电话铃响]
Hello, Nancy Updike.
你好，南希·厄普代克。
Hello.
你好。
You called just like you said.
你真的像你说的那样打来了。
I did.
我打来了。
So how may I serve you?
那么，我能为你做些什么呢？
Well, let me first explain to listeners what's going on, which is that you, Ira, have found this great story. You need to spend a couple of weeks reporting it. And you asked me to guest host the show. It's only the second time since we started the show in 1995 that we've had a guest host. But we thought it would be a lot nicer than having two weeks of reruns. So--
嗯，首先让我向听众解释一下发生了什么。你，艾拉，发现了一个很棒的故事。你需要花几周时间去报道它。你请我来客串主持这个节目。这是我们自1995年开播以来第二次有客串主持人。但我们觉得这比重播两周节目要好得多。所以——
Here we are.
我们来了。
Right. So any last dos and don'ts?
没错。那么有什么最后的注意事项吗？
No. Let me say, first of all, I just want to acknowledge you're in kind of a tough position. I think in any show on radio or television since the media began, when the host goes away, we all want what we're used to. Nobody wants change. Nobody wants the guest host.
没有。首先，我想说，我只是想承认你现在处在一个有点尴尬的境地。我认为在广播或电视媒体出现以来的任何节目中，当主持人离开时，我们都希望一切照旧。没人想要改变。没人想要客串主持人。
That is a terrible pep talk, Ira. Was that even supposed to be a pep talk?
这是一次糟糕的打气，艾拉。这真的算是打气吗？
I acknowledge it is kind of the anti-pep talk. But you are going to be great. You'll be great. Don't think about that part.
我承认这算是一种“反向打气”。但你会表现得很棒的。你会很棒的。别去想那部分。
The only thing that you actually have to know, Nance, is that there are certain things that must be said at certain moments in the show under our contracts with WBEZ Chicago and with PRI. Three times in the show, you have to say their names. And going into the break in the middle of the show, you also have to say, "when our program continues." Because the phrase "when our program continues" is the one that local stations are listening for. And when they hear that phrase, then they play their local promos.
南希，你实际上唯一需要知道的是，根据我们与芝加哥WBEZ和PRI的合同，节目中有些话在特定时刻必须说到。在节目中，你必须提到他们的名字三次。而且在节目中段进入广告前，你还必须说“当我们的节目继续时”。因为“当我们的节目继续时”这句话是当地电台在监听的信号。当他们听到这句话时，他们就会播放当地的推广内容。
And just out of curiosity, if I didn't do any of those things, any one of those things, what would happen? Just curious.
出于好奇，如果我没做其中任何一件事，会发生什么？只是好奇。
You know, truthfully I don't own know, Nancy. But I honestly don't want to find out. I'm giving you the keys to the car, and I want you to just obey a few simple rules, and everybody's going to get home safely.
说实话，南希，我不知道。但我真不想去验证。我把车的钥匙交给你，我希望你遵守几条简单的规则，这样每个人都能平安到家。
But wait, how fast does it go?
等等，这车开得有多快？
OK. So do you have the contractual language in front of you that I left for you to read now and kick off the show? Do you have it there?
好了。那么，你手边有我留给你的那段合同用语吗？现在就读它并开始节目。你有吗？
Yeah, I got it.
有，我拿着呢。
All right, so let's kick it off.
好，那我们就开始吧。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's still This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Nancy Updike.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ，节目仍是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是南希·厄普代克。
That's great.
太棒了。
See you in two weeks.
两周后再见。
OK, have fun.
好，玩得开心。
I want to tell you that there wasn't some long, behind the scenes build up to this guest hosting gig. I found out about it not that long before you did. And I'm excited to be doing it. The stories this week are great. But really what I feel is mixed. It's a little nerve wracking. I feel like I got handed one of those gifts that when you tear off the wrapping paper and see what's inside, you say, "oh, you shouldn't have." And part of you means it.
我想告诉你们，这次客串主持并没有什么幕后酝酿。我发现这件事的时间和你差不多。我很兴奋能做这件事。这周的故事都很棒。但其实我心情很复杂。这让人有点紧张。我感觉自己像收到了一份礼物，拆开包装看到里面的东西时，你会说：“哦，你本不必破费的。”而且你心里确实是这么想的。
But what are you going to do? A lot of gifts are complicated, if not flat out bad. I'm picturing-- and you can picture your own pile-- misguided sweaters, noise makers for children, lingerie for coworkers, et cetera, anything creepy. Some gifts, good gifts, say I thought of you. But plenty of others say, I thought I was thinking of you, but really I was thinking of me.
但你能怎么办呢？许多礼物即使不算彻底糟糕，也很令人困惑。我想象着——你们也可以想象自己收到的那堆礼物——搞错的毛衣、给孩子的噪音玩具、给同事的内衣等等，任何让人毛骨悚然的东西。有些礼物，好的礼物，是在说“我想到了你”。但更多的是在说，“我以为我在想你，但实际上我是在想我自己”。
Today on This American Life we will be rummaging deep into the oh, you shouldn't have gift pile to see just how fraught it all is. The giving, the receiving. Four stories. I'm going to call them stories, not acts today-- see how that feels. Four stories, four gifts.
今天在《美国生活》节目中，我们将深入挖掘那堆“你本不必破费”的礼物，看看它是多么令人纠结。给予与接收。四个故事。今天我称它们为故事，而不是片段——看看感觉如何。四个故事，四份礼物。
First, a story about a gift that was given out every week in front of 40 million people. Next, a cautionary tale about how anything you give may be used against you, sometimes in a court of law. And what to do if a certain women in Minnesota offers you an orange. Stay with us.
首先，一个每周在4000万人面前送出的礼物的故事。接下来，一个警示故事，关于你送出的任何东西都可能被用来对付你，有时甚至是在法庭上。还有，如果明尼苏达州的某位女士给你一个橙子，你该怎么办。请继续收听。
OK, our first story is from Allison Silverman. You probably know her work. She's written for The Colbert Report , The Daily Show , Late Night with Conan O'Brien , and other famous funny TV shows. She also knows a lot about TV, not just shows that are on now, but also older shows-- That Was the Week That Was , Saturday Color Carnival , The Jack Paar Show . One of the older shows she's been watching lately was built around the idea of giving people what was supposed to be the gift of a lifetime. Allison had heard of the show, but once she started watching it, she was very, very surprised by what she saw. Here's Allison.
好的，我们的第一个故事来自艾莉森·西尔弗曼。你们可能知道她的作品。她为《科尔伯特报告》、《每日秀》、《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》以及其他著名的喜剧电视节目写过剧本。她也了解很多电视知识，不仅是现在的节目，还有更早期的节目——《那是过去的一周》、《周六色彩嘉年华》、《杰克·帕尔秀》。她最近一直在看的一部老节目，其核心理念是给予人们一份终生难忘的礼物。艾莉森听说过这个节目，但当她开始观看时，她对所见内容感到非常非常惊讶。这是艾莉森。
What if someone, without your knowledge, was researching your life, organizing it, throwing out the boring bits, playing up the dramatic bits, fitting it all into a classic narrative? And one day he surprised you by putting you on live television and sharing your personal, streamlined story with, say, 40 million Americans. It happened to hundreds of people in the 1950s on a show that ran on NBC.
如果有人在你不自知的情况下，研究了你的生活，将其整理出来，丢掉无聊的部分，放大戏剧性的部分，将其装进一个经典的叙事框架中呢？有一天，他让你大吃一惊，把你拉上电视直播，与大约4000万美国人分享你那精简后的私人故事。在上世纪50年代，这发生在了数百人身上，节目在NBC播出。
This Is Your Life , America's most talk about program.
《这就是你的一生》，美国讨论度最高的节目。
There's not much talk about This Is Your Life today. If you don't know the show, here's how it worked. Every week an unsuspecting guest, often a big name celebrity, would be lured to LA's El Capitan Theater under false pretenses.
今天关于《这就是你的一生》的讨论不多。如果你不知道这个节目，它的运作方式是这样的：每周，一位毫无防备的嘉宾，通常是位大明星，会被诱骗到洛杉矶的埃尔卡皮坦剧院。
I've all you other panel members, but until this moment I haven't had the pleasure of meeting you and saying to you, Dick Clark-- Hi, Dick. Musical star-maker, America's number one disk jockey. Tonight, Dick, This Is Your Life .
我已经见过所有其他小组成员了，但直到这一刻，我才有幸见到你并对你说，迪克·克拉克——你好，迪克。音乐明星制造者，美国头号广播员。今晚，迪克，这就是你的一生。
Ralph Edwards was the host of This Is Your Life . At the beginning of every episode, he shows the stunned guest a leather-bound book with their name and the words "This Is Your Life" on it. Then he treats them to a half-hour retrospective and then reunites them with influential figures from their past. Edwards was a radio announcer who made it big when he came up with the game show Truth or Consequences . He also taught Sunday school. The combination made him the perfect host for a show designed to be inspirational entertainment.
拉尔夫·爱德华兹是《这就是你的一生》的主持人。在每一集的开头，他会向惊呆的嘉宾展示一本皮革装订的书，上面印着他们的名字和“这就是你的一生”。然后，他会让他们回顾半小时的往事，并让他们与过去中那些有影响力的人物重逢。爱德华兹曾是一名广播播音员，他在创作了游戏节目《真相还是后果》后名声大噪。他还教过主日学。这种结合使他成为这档旨在提供鼓舞人心娱乐节目的完美主持人。
After giving Dick Clark his first glimpse of the book, Edwards holds it up and reads from it. Every now and then interrupted by an off-stage voice like this one.
在让迪克·克拉克第一次瞥见那本书后，爱德华兹举起书并开始朗读。偶尔会被像这样的画外音打断。
Dick, do you remember the Green Hornet?
迪克，你还记得“青蜂侠”吗？
The voice of your pal since childhood, today an attorney for the Securities and Exchange Commission of New York City. Here from his home in Mount Vernon, New York is Andy Grass.
那是你童年玩伴的声音，如今是纽约市证券交易委员会的一名律师。从纽约弗农山的家中来到这里的是安迪·格拉斯。
Hello, Andy.
你好，安迪。
There's an archway stage right with a curtain. And through it come old friends and family. Each one talks about Dick Clark, shares a memory, and a hug.
舞台右侧有一个带帘子的拱门。老朋友和家人从那里走出来。每个人都谈论迪克·克拉克，分享一段记忆，并送上拥抱。
What was this Green Hornet, Andy?
那个“青蜂侠”是什么，安迪？
Well that was a 15 year old sedan, Ralph, that Dick and I used to have, drive around town, and pick up records for his record collection.
那是一辆15年的老轿车，拉尔夫，我和迪克过去常开着它在镇上转悠，去收集他的唱片。
It turns out Dick's childhood in Mount Vernon, New York was bright and full of mischief. But there was adversity ahead. Dick had to drive from Syracuse University to State Teachers College in Salisbury, Maryland in the middle of winter in a convertible with no heater. Still, he persevered and eventually beat the odds, marrying his high school sweetheart, landing a gig hosting American Bandstand , and blossoming into the person we know today.
事实证明，迪克在纽约弗农山的童年是明亮而充满淘气的。但未来有逆境在等着他。迪克必须在隆冬时节开着一辆没有暖气的敞篷车从锡拉丘兹大学赶到马里兰州索尔兹伯里的州立教师学院。但他坚持了下来，最终克服了重重困难，娶了他的高中甜心，得到了主持《美国音乐台》的工作，并成长为我们今天认识的那个人。
Promise, struggle, triumph. That's pretty much how all the episodes go. But watch enough of This is Your Life and you start to wonder. Putting people's past on display without warning, is it such a good idea? Because clearly some struggles are more struggly than others.
承诺、挣扎、胜利。几乎所有的剧集都是这样的套路。但看多了《这就是你的一生》，你就会开始怀疑。在没有警告的情况下把人们的过去展示出来，这真的是个好主意吗？因为显然，有些挣扎比其他挣扎更令人痛苦。
This Is Your Life Hanna Bloch Kohner.
《这就是你的一生》，汉娜·布洛赫·科纳。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
Oh, disturbingly, yes. In May 1953, Ralph Edwards surprise Hanna Bloch Kohner, whose apparent dismay at having her life story told could have something to do with the fact that a lot of her life was a staggering nightmare.
哦，令人不安的是，是的。1953年5月，拉尔夫·爱德华兹给了汉娜·布洛赫·科纳一个惊喜。她对讲述自己人生故事表现出的明显沮丧，可能与她人生中很大一部分是一场惊人的噩梦有关。
May I say, Mrs. Kohner, that looking at you, it's hard to believe that during seven short years of a still-short life you lived a lifetime of fear, terror, and tragedy. You look like a young American girl just out of college, not at all like a survivor of Hitler's cruel purge of German Jews.
我能否说，科纳夫人，看着你，很难相信在你依然短暂的生命中，那短短七年里，你经历了恐惧、恐怖和悲剧的一生。你看上去就像一个刚从大学毕业的年轻美国女孩，一点也不像希特勒残酷清洗德国犹太人的幸存者。
Hanna Bloch Kohner is a Holocaust survivor, although the word Holocaust wouldn't be used to commonly describe it for another eight years. And Ralph Edwards is right, Hanna is gorgeous and poised. For her episode, the This Is Your Life format is the same as ever. Like Dick Clark, she's supposed to remember something. Only it's not the Green Hornet.
汉娜·布洛赫·科纳是大屠杀幸存者，尽管“大屠杀”这个词在接下来的八年里才会被普遍用来描述这段历史。拉尔夫·爱德华兹说得对，汉娜美丽而从容。对于她那一集，节目形式和往常一样。像迪克·克拉克一样，她本该想起什么。只是那不是“青蜂侠”。
You and your husband are seized and shipped off to the concentration camp at Westerbork near the German border.
你和你的丈夫被捕并被送往德国边境附近的韦斯特博克集中营。
That's where I first met Hanna. We spent about eight months in that camp and though it was very tough, it didn't compare with the camps that followed.
那就是我第一次遇见汉娜的地方。我们在那个营地呆了大约八个月，虽然非常艰难，但无法与后来的营地相比。
Do you recognize that voice, Hanna? It belongs to a girl who was your friend and companion in four concentration camps. Eva Herzberg, now Mrs. Warner Florsheim.
你认得那个声音吗，汉娜？那属于一个曾是你四个集中营里的朋友和伙伴的女孩。伊娃·赫茨伯格，现在是沃纳·弗洛斯海姆夫人。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Were you and Hanna moved from that first camp together, Eva?
你和汉娜是从那个最初的营地一起被转移的吗，伊娃？
Yes, together with a lot of others. We were packed into cattle cars and shipped off to Theresienstadt in Czechoslovakia. Then we were sent off to the extermination camp at Auschwitz in Poland.
是的，和许多其他人一起。我们被塞进运牛车，被送往捷克斯洛伐克的特雷津。然后我们被送往波兰的奥斯威辛灭绝营。
You were each given a cake of soap and a towel, weren't you, Hanna?
你们每个人都得到了一块肥皂和一条毛巾，不是吗，汉娜？
I don't remember the soap.
我不记得有肥皂。
Well, you were sent to the so-called showers. And even this was a doubtful procedure because some showers had regular water, others have liquid gas. And you never knew which one you were being sent to. You and Eva were fortunate, others were not so fortunate, including your father and mother and your husband, Carl Benjamin. They all lost their lives at Auschwitz.
嗯，你们被送到了所谓的浴室。甚至这都是一个令人怀疑的过程，因为有些浴室有普通的水，有些则是液体毒气。你永远不知道自己会被送往哪一个。你和伊娃很幸运，其他人就没有那么幸运了，包括你的父亲、母亲和你的丈夫卡尔·本杰明。他们都在奥斯威辛丧生。
Now if I was surprising someone and sharing the murder of her parents and husband on national television, I would do it differently. I wouldn't do it. But somehow, in some way, Hanna's half-hour goes by without a hitch. She's reunited with her brother who she hasn't seen in 10 years.
现在，如果我是去给某人制造惊喜，并要在全国电视上分享她父母和丈夫被谋杀的故事，我会换一种方式。我不会那样做。但不知何故，汉娜的半小时节目进行得毫无波折。她与十年未见的哥哥重逢了。
This is my happiest day in all of my life.
这是我一生中最快乐的一天。
As the show's winding down, it takes a left turn. After all the excruciating details of Hanna's life in Czechoslovakia, the Netherlands, Germany, and Poland, Edwards sums up her story this way.
随着节目的临近尾声，它出现了一个转折。在历经了汉娜在捷克斯洛伐克、荷兰、德国和波兰生活的种种痛苦细节后，爱德华兹这样总结她的故事。
This is your life, Hanna Bloch Kohner. To you in your darkest hour, America held out a friendly hand. Your gratitude is reflected in your unwavering devotion and loyalty to the land of your adoption.
这就是你的一生，汉娜·布洛赫·科纳。在你最黑暗的时刻，美国向你伸出了友好的援手。你的感激之情反映在你对这片接纳你的土地坚定不移的忠诚上。
It seems out of nowhere at first. But this is May 1953. It's less than a month before the execution of the Rosenbergs. Calling anyone a patriot in front of 40 million Americans is nice. Calling a Jewish immigrant from Czechoslovakia, a communist country, a patriot is more than nice. It's one of the best presents she can get. And Edwards gives Hanna other presents too, the kind you can bring home.
这起初看起来有些突兀。但这是1953年5月。距离罗森堡夫妇被处决不到一个月。在4000万美国人面前称呼任何人是一个爱国者都很好。称呼一位来自共产党国家捷克斯洛伐克的犹太移民为爱国者就不仅仅是好那么简单了。这是她能得到的最棒的礼物之一。爱德华兹还给了汉娜其他礼物，那种你可以带回家的礼物。
Oh yes, so that you and Walter can relive this memorable night again and again, Hazel Bishop is presenting you with a 16 millimeter sound film of this program, you see, together with a 16 millimeter sound projector. Now, as a lasting memento of your appearance here, Marshall Jewelers, 5th Avenue at 56th Street, New York City, have designed for you this lovely 14 karat gold charm bracelet. Now, each charm represents an important event in your life.
哦，是的，为了让你和沃尔特能一次又一次地重温这个难忘的夜晚，Hazel Bishop将赠送你这份节目的16毫米有声电影，你看，还有一台16毫米有声放映机。现在，作为你出现在这里的永久纪念，位于纽约市第5大道56街的Marshall Jewelers为你设计了这条精美的14克拉金质吊坠手链。现在，每一个吊坠都代表了你生命中的一个重要事件。
Can't be easy to design a Holocaust charm bracelet. To their credit, Marshall Jewelers played it safe, with a 14 karat map of Czechoslovakia, a mountain house, a Jeep, a sergeant's hat, a suitcase, a star of David, the Statue of Liberty, the flags of Luxembourg, where Hanna was married, and the United States. It was actually nice. It's the kind of Holocaust charm bracelet you pass down to your kids.
设计一条大屠杀吊坠手链肯定不容易。值得称赞的是，Marshall Jewelers选择了安全牌，用14克拉的金做了捷克斯洛伐克的地图、一座山间小屋、一辆吉普车、一顶军士帽、一个手提箱、一颗大卫之星、自由女神像、汉娜结婚地卢森堡的旗帜以及美国国旗。这其实很不错。这是一种你会传给孩子的“大屠杀吊坠手链”。
There's something undeniably strange about all of this. The overworked language, the wholesome, all-American spirit forced into a foreigner's tragedy, the game show tactics, a Holocaust survivor asked to guess who's next to come through the curtain. But Ralph Edwards was trying to do good. His model for the show was love thy neighbor. And though Hanna Kohner's episode was, well, blunt, it was the first national television show to have a Holocaust survivor tell her story. There were just no rules for how you do it.
这一切确实有一种说不出的奇怪。言过其实的语言、强加给一个外国人悲剧的健全的、全美式的精神、游戏节目的套路、一位被要求猜测下一个进门者是谁的大屠杀幸存者。但拉尔夫·爱德华兹是在尝试做好事。他节目的理念是“爱你的邻居”。尽管汉娜·科纳的那一集，嗯，显得直白，但这是第一个让大屠杀幸存者讲述自己故事的全国性电视节目。当时确实没有任何规则可循。
The show was huge. One in four Americans watched This Is Your Life every week. And Edwards used the attention to help people. When Hanna's episode aired, This Is Your Life donated to United Jewish Appeal and set up a fund for viewers to donate to.
这个节目非常火。每四个美国人中就有一个每周观看《这就是你的一生》。爱德华兹利用这种关注来帮助人们。当汉娜的那一集播出时，《这就是你的一生》向美国犹太联合呼吁基金会捐了款，并为观众设立了一个捐款基金。
Of course, the show didn't tackle epic tragedy just once. They went even bigger two years later.
当然，这个节目不仅仅只处理过一次史诗般的悲剧。两年后，他们做得更大了。
In 1955, This Is Your Life surprised Kiyoshi Tanimoto, a Methodist minister from Japan who was in the States on a humanitarian mission. He had been flown from New York to LA and brought to the El Capitan Theater for what he thought would be a straightforward interview about his work.
1955年，《这就是你的一生》给了谷本清一个惊喜，他是一位来自日本的卫理公会牧师，当时正在美国执行人道主义任务。他从纽约飞往洛杉矶，被带到埃尔卡皮坦剧院，本以为是一次关于他工作的直接采访。
You though, of course, you were going to be interviewed as a part of the work you're now doing, didn't you? What is that work, sir, that you are doing right now at the present moment?
你当然认为你是作为你现在所从事的工作的一部分来接受采访的，对吧？先生，你此刻正在做的那项工作是什么？
Well, I brought a group of girls who have terrible disfigurement on event of atomic explosion in Hiroshima.
嗯，我带了一群在日本广岛原子弹爆炸中严重毁容的女孩。
And you have accompanied these girls over?
你是陪同这些女孩过来的？
Yes. And we are hoping to have plastic surgery for them.
是的。我们希望能为她们进行整形手术。
Tanimoto was a survivor of the atomic bombing of Hiroshima, and he had brought 25 young women disfigured by the bombing to the US. They were called the Hiroshima Maidens, and they were scheduled to have reconstructive surgery at Mount Sinai Hospital in New York City. Tanimoto had come up with the idea. He had two of the Maidens with him at the theater. He was trying to raise money.
谷本清是广岛原子弹爆炸的幸存者，他带了25名被爆炸毁容的年轻女性来到美国。她们被称为“广岛少女”，原定在纽约市西奈山医院接受重建手术。谷本清想到了这个主意。他在剧院里带着两名少女。他当时正在试图筹集资金。
Now Reverend Tanimoto, are you ready to turn the pages in this book and share with us your experiences? All right, then, August 6, 1945, Hiroshima, Japan.
现在，谷本牧师，你准备好翻开这本书并与我们分享你的经历了吗？好的，1945年8月6日，日本广岛。
This is the first time I've heard the words Hiroshima, Japan and expected them to be followed with "Come on down."
这是我第一次听到“日本广岛”这几个字，并期待后面接的是“快过来”。
Edwards wastes no time. He starts with the day a nuclear bomb on Tanimoto's city. As for Tanimoto, he sits on the couch next to Edwards, confused by what the leather-bound book has to do with any of this. As Edwards opens it, Tanimoto looks down at the book, then up at Edwards. Then back to the book, and back to Edward again. But in fact, in this episode, the book plays second fiddle to a lot of actual fiddles and horns and various sound effects.
爱德华兹毫不拖延。他从原子弹投向谷本牧师所在城市的那一天讲起。至于谷本清，他坐在爱德华兹旁边的沙发上，对这本皮革装订的书与这一切有什么关系感到困惑。当爱德华兹打开它时，谷本清看向书，然后看向爱德华兹。然后又看向书，又看向爱德华兹。但事实上，在这一集中，这本书比起许多实际的提琴、号角和各种音效来说，只是个配角。
The morning is quite and very peaceful.
早晨非常安静和平。
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
[戏剧性音乐]
The time has come, that split second of eternity which comes in one way or another to every man in his lifetime. What did you do when you heard that bomb?
时候到了，那是永恒的一瞬间，以这样或那样的方式降临到每个人的生命中。当你听到那颗炸弹时，你做了什么？
Well, I didn't hear any sounds, but I saw strange flash running through the air. And took a couple of steps into the garden and lie down on the ground. And I felt strong blast of wind. And then I wake up, I mean I got up and saw many houses behind me destroyed.
嗯，我没有听到任何声音，但我看到奇怪的闪光穿过空气。我走了几步走进花园，趴在地上。我感觉到一阵强风。然后我醒了，我是说我站起来，看到我身后的许多房子被摧毁了。
You were between two rocks?
你当时在两块岩石之间？
I saw the whole city on fire and many people running away from the city in silence. Their skin peeling off, and hanging from face, from arm. But, strange to say, in silence, it looked like procession of ghosts.
我看到整个城市在燃烧，许多人默默地从城里逃出来。他们的皮肤在剥落，从脸上、手臂上垂下来。但是，奇怪的是，在沉默中，看起来像是一群鬼魂在游行。
Edwards cues the jingling Buddhist temple bells and the show jarringly flashes back to Reverend Tanimoto's youth.
爱德华兹发出了叮当响的佛教寺庙钟声，节目突兀地闪回到谷本牧师的青年时代。
First through the curtain is an old woman, the Methodist missionary who introduced him to Christianity. Then it's an old buddy from seminary school who tells a story about Tanimoto chasing girls. After him, a man appears in silhouette behind a screen. Tanimoto hears this voice.
首先从帘子后面走出来的是一位老妇人，那位介绍他皈依基督教的卫理公会传教士。然后是他在神学院的老朋友，讲了一个关于谷本清追女孩的故事。在他之后，一个男人出现在屏幕后的剪影中。谷本清听到了这个声音。
Looking down from thousands of feet over Hiroshima, all I could think of was, "My God, what have we done?"
从数千英尺高空俯瞰广岛，我能想到的只有：“上帝啊，我们做了什么？”
The voice of a man whose second of eternity was woven up with yours, Reverend Tanimoto. Now you've never met him, have never seen him, but he's here tonight to clasp your hand in friendship. Captain Robert Lewis, United States Air Force, who, along with Paul Tibbets, piloted the plane from which the first atomic power was dropped over Hiroshima.
那个人的声音，他的永恒瞬间与你的交织在一起，谷本牧师。你从未见过他，从未见过他，但他今晚来到这里，想与你握手言和。美国空军罗伯特·刘易斯上尉，他与保罗·蒂贝茨一起驾驶了那架在日本广岛投下第一枚原子弹的飞机。
[MUSIC AND APPLAUSE]
[音乐和掌声]
Captain Lewis, come in here close. And would you tell us, sir, of your experience on August 6, 1945?
刘易斯上尉，靠近点。先生，你能告诉我们你在1945年8月6日的经历吗？
Well Mr. Edwards--
嗯，爱德华兹先生——
Captain Lewis, co-pilot of the Enola Gay, shares a handshake with Tanimoto, who then backs, up putting him at an awkward distance between Lewis and Ralph Edwards, who's still consulting his book. Captain Lewis explains haltingly how they got the order to target Hiroshima, how the bombardier aimed, how they dropped the bomb and then turned fast to avoid the blast.
刘易斯上尉，“艾诺拉·盖”号的副驾驶，与谷本清握了手，谷本清随后退后，让自己处于刘易斯和仍在查阅书籍的拉尔夫·爱德华兹之间一个尴尬的距离。刘易斯上尉断断续续地解释了他们是如何接到针对广岛的命令，投弹手是如何瞄准的，他们是如何投下炸弹然后快速转向以避开爆炸的。
And then the two concussion waves hit the ship. Shortly after, we turned back to see what had happened. And there in front of our eyes, the city of Hiroshima disappeared.
然后两道冲击波击中了飞机。不久之后，我们调头回去看发生了什么。在我们眼前，广岛市消失了。
Now you entered something in your log at that time.
你当时在航行日志中写了些什么。
As I said before, Mr. Edwards, I wrote down later, "My God, what have we done?"
就像我之前说的，爱德华兹先生，我后来写下：“上帝啊，我们做了什么？”
And so, Reverend Tanimoto, you on the ground, and you on your military mission, Captain Lewis, in the air, both appealed to a power greater than your own.
所以，谷本牧师，你在地面，而你在执行军事任务，刘易斯上尉，在空中，你们都向上帝祈求了超越你们自身的力量。
Lewis is the one you're most worried about watching this bizarre blind date. Ralph Edwards is pleased. Tanimoto is respectful, but Captain Lewis looks like he's breaking down. People say he went to a bar before the show and came back drunk.
刘易斯是你看这场奇怪的盲约时最担心的人。拉尔夫·爱德华兹很满意。谷本清很恭敬，但刘易斯上尉看起来快崩溃了。人们说他在节目开始前去酒吧喝醉了才回来。
Thank you, Captain Robert Lewis, now personnel manager of Henry Heide Incorporated in New York City.
谢谢你，罗伯特·刘易斯上尉，现在是纽约市Henry Heide公司的劳工经理。
In 1971, Lewis sold his famous log from the flight and used the money in part to buy Italian marble for his new hobby, sculpture. The piece he's known for is a mushroom cloud, with streams of blood flowing down the side.
1971年，刘易斯卖掉了那本著名的飞行日志，并用这笔钱买了意大利大理石作为他的新爱好——雕塑。他最著名的作品是一朵蘑菇云，侧面流淌着血流。
Edwards then introduces the two Hiroshima Maidens, who are only seen in silhouette, brings on Tanimoto's wife and four kids.
爱德华兹随后介绍了那两位只能看到剪影的广岛少女，带出了谷本清的妻子和四个孩子。
Koko, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
Koko，[听不清的短语]。
And gives viewers at home an address to send their donations.
并给在家里的观众一个寄送捐款的地址。
The address again, Maidens, Box 200, New York One, New York.
地址再说一遍，Maidens, Box 200, New York One, New York。
And if you'll accept a change of mood now, I'd like to tell you a bit about wonderful, extra rich, liquid Prell shampoo. That's the thrilling new companion to Prell in the tube.
如果你现在能接受气氛的转变，我想告诉你一些关于精彩、超浓郁、液体Prell洗发水的事情。那是Prell管装洗发水的激动人心的新搭档。
Even in its heyday, This Is Your Life raised hackles. Time magazine called Ralph Edwards a "spiritual prosecutor" to his guests. And Jack Gould at the New York Times accused the show and others like it of exploiting the raw and private emotions of the unfortunate. But the unfortunate, they liked it. This Is Your Life might have exploited your story, but it also told you your story, gave it to you. And once you had it you could do whatever you wanted with it.
即使在鼎盛时期，《这就是你的一生》也招致了反感。《时代》杂志称拉尔夫·爱德华兹是客人的“精神检察官”。《纽约时报》的杰克·古尔德指责该节目及其他类似节目剥削了不幸者原始而私人的情感。但那些不幸的人，他们喜欢它。《这就是你的一生》可能剥削了你的故事，但它也讲述了你的故事，把它交给了你。一旦你拥有了它，你想怎么做都可以。
Hanna's daughter, Julie Kohner, told me that her mother spent the year after the show traveling around the country with a copy of her episode, raising money for United Jewish Appeal. On Passover, the Kohner family would play it on the gift projector they got on This Is Your Life . Years later, Hanna and her husband, Walter, even published a joint autobiography, Hanna and Walter: A Love Story .
汉娜的女儿朱莉·科纳告诉我，她母亲在节目播出后的一年里，带着她那集节目的拷贝在全国旅行，为美国犹太联合呼吁基金会筹款。在逾越节，科纳一家会在他们在《这就是你的一生》中得到的礼物放映机上播放它。多年后，汉娜和她的丈夫沃尔特甚至出版了一本联合自传，《汉娜与沃尔特：一个爱情故事》。
And as brutal as his episode seems today, Reverend Kiyoshi Tanimoto had fond memories of his appearance. His daughter, Koko Kondo, who was on the telecast as a 10-year-old told me when English-speaking guests would visit, Tanimoto would play them the episode on his gift projector. He wasn't horrified by meeting Captain Lewis, the co-pilot of the Enola Gay. In fact, the two of them started writing each other after the show. And Koko Kondo says Captain Lewis changed her whole attitude about the old enemy. Seeing him tear up on stage at the El Capitan, she stopped hating American soldiers.
而且尽管谷本清的那一集在今天看来很残酷，但他对自己的出镜有美好的回忆。当她在电视节目中作为10岁的孩子出镜时，他的女儿Koko Kondo告诉我，当说英语的客人来访时，谷本清会在他的礼物放映机上给他们播放那一集。他并没有因为见到“艾诺拉·盖”号的副驾驶刘易斯上尉而感到恐惧。事实上，节目后他们开始互相通信。Koko Kondo说刘易斯上尉改变了她对老敌人的整个态度。看到他在埃尔卡皮坦的舞台上流泪，她停止了对美国士兵的仇恨。
And sometimes the show did even more. Once in a while, getting your life story from This Is Your Life actually changed the story of your life. And if you'll accept a change in mood now, our last example from the show is Lillian Roth, a vaudeville singing star who made it big on Broadway and then in movies like Animal Crackers with the Marx brothers. She was America's top jazz baby.
有时这个节目做得更多。偶尔，从《这就是你的一生》中获得你的人生故事确实改变了你的人生故事。如果你现在能接受气氛的转变，我们来自该节目的最后一个例子是莉莲·罗斯，一位杂耍歌唱明星，在百老汇以及与马克思兄弟合作的《动物饼干》等电影中大获成功。她是美国顶尖的“爵士宝贝”。
But in 1953, when she came on This Is Your Life she was pretty much forgotten. The leather-bound book starts in a sad place.
但在1953年，当她来到《这就是你的一生》时，她几乎被遗忘了。皮革装订的书从一个悲伤的地方开始。
This is the Bloomingdale Hospital for Nervous and Mental Diseases, now known as the New York Hospital, Westchester Division. The year is 1946. You're a patient of this mental hospital. Why, Lillian?
这是布鲁明代尔神经和精神疾病医院，现在被称为纽约医院，韦斯特切斯特分院。那一年是1946年。你是这家精神病院的病人。为什么，莉莲？
Well, I had a problem. Alcoholism, which led to a mental breakdown.
嗯，我有一个问题。酗酒，导致了精神崩溃。
For nearly 16 years, right? Up to 1945, there'd hardly been a day or a night that you drew a sober breath.
持续了近16年，对吧？直到1945年，几乎没有一天或一个晚上你是清醒的。
That's right.
没错。
Edwards later calls this time "a stupor that was to last for 16 years." And as he recounts Roth's past, we cut to a shot of a placard with the date plus an empty whiskey bottle. The next time we cut it's two empty whiskey bottles. Then two empty whiskey bottles, plus another lying on its side. And finally, the two empty whiskey bottles, the one lying on its side, and a huge whiskey bottle made for a giant.
爱德华兹后来称这段时间为“持续了16年的昏迷”。当他叙述罗斯的过去时，我们切换到一个带有日期和一个空威士忌酒瓶的标牌镜头。下一次切换时是两个空威士忌酒瓶。然后是两个空威士忌酒瓶，加上另一个侧躺着的。最后是那两个空酒瓶、那个侧躺着的和一个为巨人制作的巨大威士忌酒瓶。
But you still may not have gotten the idea about Lillian.
但你可能还是没明白莉莲的事。
1932, your first marriage, consummated while under the influence of drink, is dissolved in drink. You're married again to a distinguished young New York judge. On your honeymoon to Miami, Florida, he opens your trunk and finds it filled with liquor.
1932年，你的第一次婚姻，在酒精的影响下达成，也在酒精中解体。你又嫁给了一位杰出的年轻纽约法官。在你们去佛罗里达迈阿密的蜜月旅行中，他打开你的行李箱，发现里面装满了酒。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
I think that tune is called "Trunk Full of Liquor."
我想那首曲子叫“装满酒的行李箱”。
Lillian Roth was the first and one of the only This Is Your Life guests who knew she'd be on the show ahead of time. She was asked by Ralph Edwards if she would let him share her story. And she did, because she thought it could help someone. The episode was a smash, and among the people it helped, happily, was Lillian Roth.
莉莲·罗斯是第一位，也是唯一几位提前知道自己会参加节目的《这就是你的一生》嘉宾之一。她被拉尔夫·爱德华兹问及是否愿意让他分享她的故事。她答应了，因为她认为这可以帮助别人。那一集大获成功，高兴的是，受益的人中就有莉莲·罗斯。
Following her reintroduction to America on the show, Roth wrote an autobiography that spent 44 weeks on the New York Times Bestseller List. It's called I'll Cry Tomorrow . And in it, she calls her appearance on This Is Your Life a miracle. I'll Cry Tomorrow was made into a movie starring Susan Hayward, who was Oscar nominated for her nuanced, understated, and minutely observed performance.
在节目重新向美国介绍她之后，罗斯写了一本自传，在《纽约时报》畅销书榜单上停留了44周。书名叫《明天我会哭》。在书中，她称自己参加《这就是你的一生》是一个奇迹。《明天我会哭》被改编成电影，由苏珊·海沃德主演，她因其细腻、低调和细致入微的表演获得了奥斯卡提名。
I don't want a drink, but I need a drink. I need a drink! Now!
我不想喝酒，但我需要喝酒。我需要喝酒！现在！
The action builds to its final triumphant scenes, a dramatic dramatization of the moment Roth decided to allow her life to be dramatized.
情节推进到其最后的胜利场景，这是对罗斯决定让她的人生被戏剧化这一时刻的戏剧化演绎。
They want me on a national television show.
他们想要我在一个全国电视节目中出镜。
How wonderful.
多棒啊。
But they don't want me to sing.
但他们不让我唱歌。
Well, what do they want you to do?
嗯，他们想让你做什么？
They want me to come out to California and get up before 40 million people and tell the shameful, disgusting story of my life.
他们想让我去加州，站在4000万人面前，讲述我生活中那段可耻、令人作呕的故事。
The story of your life?
你的人生故事？
I couldn't tell the story of my life, I'd be too ashamed.
我讲不出我的人生故事，我会太羞耻的。
These days, confessional culture is everywhere. It's easy look down on it as nothing but a bid for publicity. But it's not really just about the person confessing. It's about why we're paying attention to their story. When we hear someone lay it all out there, there's a reason beyond voyeurism that we like to listen.
这些日子，忏悔文化随处可见。很容易将其贬低为仅仅是一种宣传噱头。但这不仅仅是关于忏悔的那个人。这是关于为什么我们关注他们的故事。当我们听到某人倾诉一切时，我们喜欢倾听，背后有一个超越偷窥的原因。
In 1958, Lillian Roth was interviewed by Mike Wallace. She said it best.
1958年，莉莲·罗斯接受了迈克·华莱士的采访。她表达得最好。
Have you ever wondered, though, why the American public seems to be so fascinated with this kind of story? Is it possibly just the desire to look across the courtyard into somebody else's open window?
不过，你有没有想过，为什么美国公众似乎对这种故事如此着迷？这可能仅仅是想隔着庭院窥视别人家开着的窗户的渴望吗？
Well, I think where my story is concerned, it goes back to an old philosophy that I read that said, "In each man's heart, there's a secret sorrow that the world knows nothing about." And I think that humanity feel that their sorrow is for you and their compassion is for you. But it has touched a part of their heart that they will not open the door themselves. They won't even peek in. And in the subconscious, the tie is there.
嗯，我认为就我的故事而言，这可以追溯到我读过的一句古老哲学，它说：“在每个人的心中，都有一个世界一无所知的秘密悲伤。”我认为人类觉得他们的悲伤是你的，他们的同情心是你的。但这触动了他们心中连自己都不愿打开门的那一部分。他们甚至不愿偷看。而在潜意识里，这种联系就在那里。
What she's saying is, when you watch me discuss my sad life on This Is Your Life it's not me who's revealed, it's you.
她想说的是，当你看着我在《这就是你的一生》中讨论我悲伤的生活时，揭露的不是我，而是你。
Allison Silverman.
艾莉森·西尔弗曼。
[MUSIC- "I"LL CRY TOMORROW"  BY LILLIAN ROTH]
[音乐 - 莉莲·罗斯演唱的“明天我会哭”]
OK, turning to our next story of gifts and their aftermath, here's a headline that caught my eye a while back. I've got the newspaper here. Big, screaming headline above the fold, "Medical Marijuana Outlet Nabbed for Overselling in Sting Operation."
好的，转向我们的下一个关于礼物及其后果的故事，这是前段时间引起我注意的一条头条新闻。我这里有报纸。标题又大又惊人，在头版上方：“医疗大麻门店因在钓鱼执法中超额销售被查”。
This is not a US newspaper, by the way. I've been living in the Middle East for a lot of the past year, and one of the newspapers I read is called Haaretz. It's an Israeli paper. You can look it up online. It has an English edition. And I'll be honest, my interest in this story was entirely escapist. I needed a break from reading about the politics in the region and "Medical Marijuana Outlet Nabbed for Overselling in Sting Operation." I was looking forward to drug deals and scandal, and people getting nabbed.
顺便说一下，这不是美国的报纸。过去的一年里，我大部分时间都住在中东，我阅读的报纸之一叫《国土报》。这是一份以色列报纸。你们可以在网上查到。它有英文版。老实说，我对这个故事的兴趣完全是为了逃避现实。我需要从阅读该地区的政治新闻中休息一下，而“医疗大麻门店因钓鱼执法被查”这个标题吸引了我。我期待着毒品交易和丑闻，以及人们被抓捕。
So here I am, I'm reading this story. And it turns out the sting consists of an undercover policewoman going to a government licensed medical marijuana center and pretending to have cancer. It says here she had a prescription for medical marijuana and she went to this place several times to get her allowed dosage. But she kept saying she was still suffering, her dose wasn't enough. She needed more.
所以我就在这里读着这个故事。原来钓鱼行动包括一名卧底女警去一家政府许可的医疗大麻中心，假装自己患有癌症。上面写着她有医疗大麻处方，她去了这个地方几次以获得允许的剂量。但她一直说她还在受苦，她的剂量不够。她需要更多。
According to one unnamed source in the story she, quote, "begged repeatedly for more cannabis, saying she could not stand the pain." Finally, someone at the place caved and gave her more. About a third of an ounce, according to the paper. Picture around half a baggy, a couple of handfuls. That was the drug deal caught by the sting. Someone giving a supposedly sick person who had a prescription a bit more marijuana than she was prescribed after being begged by the person who was pretending to have cancer.
根据报道中的一位匿名消息来源，她引用说：“反复乞求更多的大麻，说她无法忍受疼痛。”最后，那个地方的某个人屈服了，给了她更多。据报纸说，大约三分之一盎司。想象一下大约半个塑料袋，两把大麻。那就是钓鱼行动抓获的毒品交易。有人在被一个假装患有癌症、有处方的人苦苦哀求后，给了这个所谓生病的人一点比她处方量多一点点的大麻。
When I finished the story all I could think was, wait, really?
当我读完这个故事时，我能想到的只有，等等，真的吗？
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
This is Gal Cohen. She's the one who gave the undercover police women the extra medical marijuana. Through an interpreter, Gal described meeting the policewoman.
这是盖尔·科恩。她就是那个给卧底女警额外医疗大麻的人。通过翻译，盖尔描述了遇见那个女警的情景。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
I met her for the first time three months ago. She described suffering from cancer and that her condition was so severe that she doesn't leave the house much. And I remember telling her that it would be good for her to leave the house. And I even remember her coming back at some point and saying, "Thank you for telling me to come to the shop to leave the house. It has been good for me to see people."
我三个月前第一次见到她。她描述自己患有癌症，病情非常严重，以至于她很少出门。我记得我告诉她，出门对她会有好处。我甚至记得她在某个时候回来，说：“谢谢你告诉我来店里走走，出门对我很有帮助。能见到人真好。”
Quick background here. Medical marijuana is pretty new in Israel. Like the US, the country has a serious illegal drug trade to worry about. And with marijuana they're in that awkward stage of trying to figure out exactly how they want to make this still illegal drug available as medicine in some harsh cases-- cancer, AIDS, MS, chronic pain. About 6,000 people in Israel have prescriptions now.
这里简单背景一下。医疗大麻在以色列还很新。和美国一样，这个国家有严重的非法毒品贸易需要担心。而在大麻问题上，他们处于一个尴尬阶段，试图弄清楚在某些严重病例——癌症、艾滋病、多发性硬化症、慢性疼痛——中，他们究竟想如何让这种仍然是非法的毒品作为药物提供。现在大约有6000名以色列人有处方。
The police wouldn't answer questions for this story, just said it was an ongoing investigation. So I went to the medical marijuana center, called Tikun Olam, to hear their version of what happened.
警方没有回答关于这个故事的问题，只说这是一项正在进行的调查。所以我去了那家叫Tikun Olam的医疗大麻中心，去听听他们对所发生事情的版本。
Gal, the woman who gave extra to the policewoman, is 20-years-old, maybe five two, long, dark hair, reserved. In the raid, she was taken into police custody, along with her brother, who started the medical marijuana company, and another employee, Shmuel [? Desolet Mushasha. ?] As Gal was describing the undercover policewoman, Shmuel came over and jumped in.
盖尔，那个给女警额外大麻的女人，20岁，大概1米58，留着长长的黑发，很内向。在突袭中，她和她的哥哥（大麻公司的创始人）以及另一名员工什穆尔一起被警方拘留。当盖尔在描述卧底女警时，什穆尔走过来插话了。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
She looked like a lot of other people who come in who are having a hard time or in pain and maybe financially having a hard time finishing the month on whatever salaries they have.
她看起来就像其他许多来这里的人一样，他们正经历困难或疼痛，也许在财务上很难熬过这个月。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
You're showing Gal her sweater is, what? It's askew, and she's got-- she's wearing a big sweater.
你向盖尔展示她的毛衣是，什么？歪歪扭扭的，而且她穿着一件大毛衣。
Big sweater, clumsy sweater.
大毛衣，笨拙的毛衣。
Hairs everywhere. And weird glasses or something.
到处都是头发。还有奇怪的眼镜什么的。
The glasses was OK.
眼镜还可以。
The glasses was OK?
眼镜还可以？
Shmuel is 27. He's Ethiopian. His family emigrated to Israel when he was a baby. Natural storyteller. He says lots of people ask for more. And some of them push hard, like the policewoman did.
什穆尔27岁。他是埃塞俄比亚人。他还是婴儿时随家人移居以色列。天生的讲故事高手。他说很多人要求更多。有些人态度强硬，就像那个女警一样。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
I can't even tell you the kinds of episodes that we've seen here. And I'll give you one example. There are times where people will fake a heart attack. We had a guy who said he's going into cardiac arrest. You know, he was shaking and he was faking this heart attack. And I was on the phone with the ambulance. And we were so far along that the woman on the other side of the phone was saying, "Well, should I send one or not?" But as soon as he saw that I was calling the ambulance, he said, "Actually, I'm fine. Don't call the ambulance." So people go to great lengths to try to get us to give them more than they are allowed to get.
我甚至无法告诉你我们在这里看到的各种事件。我给你举个例子。有时人们会假装心脏病发作。我们有个家伙说他要心脏骤停了。你知道，他在颤抖，他在假装心脏病发作。我当时正在和救护车通话。我们已经进行得很深入了，电话那头的女人在说：“嗯，我该派救护车吗？”但一旦他看到我在叫救护车，他说：“其实我很好。别叫救护车。”所以人们会竭尽全力试图让我们给他们比允许量更多的药物。
Were you there the day of the fake heart attack?
假装心脏病发作那天你在场吗？
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
He even took his false teeth out.
他甚至把假牙都拿下来了。
Why? To add to the drama, why?
为什么？为了增加戏剧性，为什么？
The drama.
为了戏剧性。
Why this man thought a fake heart attack would get him more medical marijuana is not clear.
为什么这个人认为假装心脏病发作能让他得到更多医疗大麻，原因尚不清楚。
The undercover policewoman's drama succeeded where the heart attack man's failed, maybe because it was more subtle and had a good supporting cast. Once during the two and a half months she was going to the dispensary, she brought in a distraught husband.
那个卧底女警的戏码成功了，而那个心脏病发作的人失败了，也许是因为她的戏更含蓄，而且有很好的配角。在她去药房的两个半月里，有一次她带进了一个心烦意乱的丈夫。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
He talked, the husband, about the fact that she was-- when the pain was strong she would just lie on the coach, and she wouldn't want to move and she wouldn't want to leave the house. And here she got a little bit better and this was good, but now she's having a regression. And once again, she doesn't want to leave the house. She doesn't want to get up off the coach. That was the way he was pressing us to give her more.
那个丈夫谈到，当疼痛剧烈时，她只会躺在沙发上，不想动，不想出门。在这里她好了一点，这很好，但现在她又复发了。她又不想出门了。她不想从沙发上起来。那就是他逼我们给她更多大麻的方式。
Shmuel didn't give her more. He says he told her the same thing he tells everyone. If your dose isn't enough, talk to the health ministry and get them to increase your prescription. He says he explains to people exactly how to do it, so they don't get tangled up in the bureaucracy. And he knows the procedure because he's done it. He lost the lower half of his leg serving in the army, and he's got a prescription for medical marijuana himself. It took six months of surgery and a year and a half of rehab for him to be able to walk with a prosthetic limb. But he still has pain. Marijuana dials it down without turning him into a zombie, like morphine did. So Shmuel told the policewoman, "Go back to the health ministry." But Gal gave in.
什穆尔没给她更多。他说他告诉了她同样的话，他告诉每个人的话。如果你的剂量不够，去和卫生部谈，让他们增加你的处方。他说他向人们解释了确切的操作方法，这样他们就不会陷入官僚主义的泥潭。他知道程序，因为他自己做过。他在服兵役时失去了半条腿，他自己也有医疗大麻处方。他经历了六个月的手术和一年半的康复，才能够用假肢行走。但他仍然感到疼痛。大麻减轻了疼痛，而没有像吗啡那样让他变成僵尸。所以什穆尔告诉女警，“回卫生部去。”但盖尔屈服了。
She came back after she had run out of her supply, she said. And she said that she's desperate. She really needs it. She can't function. She said, "I'm sitting at home crying. I'm not functioning with my children and I need more." And that's when I picked up additional grams and give it to her.
她说，她用完了供应后回来。她说她绝望了。她真的需要它。她无法正常工作。她说：“我坐在家里哭。我无法照顾我的孩子，我需要更多。”就在那时，我拿出额外的克数给了她。
Gal says this wasn't a financial transaction, by the way. No money changed hands. People with medical marijuana prescriptions in Israel pay a fixed amount per month, around $100, whether they're dose is 30 grams or 100 grams. Gal just not gave it to the woman. It was an impulsive, illegal gift. Two weeks later, police showed up.
顺便说一下，盖尔说这不是经济交易。没有金钱易手。在以色列，有医疗大麻处方的人每月支付固定金额，大约100美元，无论他们的剂量是30克还是100克。盖尔只是没给那个女人。这是一次冲动、非法的赠予。两周后，警察出现了。
They took me to the police station in a big van, a big Savana van with two policeman, one at each side, two in the front, and three behind me. It felt like I was some big time drug dealer.
他们把我带进了一辆大货车，一辆大的Savana货车，两边各坐一个警察，前排两个，我身后三个。感觉就像我是什么大毒枭一样。
It wasn't until the police officer who interrogated Gal pulled out a picture of the undercover policewoman that she understood what was going on and why she'd been brought in. He asked her why she gave the woman more.
直到审讯盖尔的警察拿出一张卧底女警的照片，她才明白发生了什么，为什么她被带走。他问她为什么给那个女人更多。
I told him that I felt sorry for her. And that I had mixed up my emotions with my job. I told him it was very hard for me as a 20-year-old young woman to say no to this woman who was like my mother or my grandmother. My intention was to help her. She was an older woman.
我告诉他我同情她。我把我的情绪和工作混为一谈了。我告诉他，作为一个20岁的年轻女性，对这个像我母亲或祖母一样的女人说不，对我来说太难了。我的本意是帮助她。她是一位年长的女性。
The day I went to the one-room dispensary where Gal and Shmuel work, almost all the patients who came in were women who fit the description of the undercover officer. All past 50, bundled up, moving slowly. Shmuel asked one of them, "How's it going?" And she said, "not good."
我去的那个单间药房，盖尔和什穆尔在那里工作，几乎所有进来的病人都符合那个卧底警察描述的形象。都50多岁了，裹得严严实实，动作缓慢。什穆尔问其中一个，“怎么样？”她说，“不好。”
I've always thought the expression you can't cheat an honest man was off base. Of course you can. The way you do it is to appeal not to their greed, but to their pity. Convince them they're doing something for your gain, not theirs. Government prosecutors are deciding whether to indict anyone in the case.
我一直认为“你不能欺骗一个诚实的人”这句话是错的。你当然可以。方法就是诉诸他们的怜悯，而不是贪婪。说服他们是在为你而不是为他们做某事。政府检察官正在决定是否要对案件中的任何人提起诉讼。
Coming up, gold fish and a battle over dried fruit. That's in one minute. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International when-- say it with me-- when our program continues.
接下来，金鱼和关于干果的战斗。那一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，当——跟我一起说——当我们的节目继续时。
Welcome back. I'm Nancy Updike sitting in for Ira Glass, who's out reporting a story for two weeks. It's This American Life and we have a theme this week, like we do every week. And today it is, "Oh, You Shouldn't Have." We're looking at some of the hazards and joys of giving and receiving gifts, from huge ones like a TV special about your life, to ones as small as a lowly orange.
欢迎回来。我是南希·厄普代克，替艾拉·格拉斯主持节目，他外出去报道一个故事两周。这是《美国生活》，我们每周都有一个主题。今天的主题是，“哦，你本不必破费的”。我们正在审视赠送和接受礼物的一些危险和乐趣，从像关于你一生的电视特辑那样巨大的礼物，到像一个小橙子那样微小的礼物。
Let's talk for a minute about etiquette. I think there's something almost un-American about etiquette. I know there are people who will disagree with me on this, but I think for a lot of Americans the idea that there are rules out there about the proper way to behave, rules more elaborate than just common sense, seems pretentious, European, like one more thing we fought the British to be free of. Not that we're rude, we just don't like to be fancy.
让我们谈谈礼仪。我认为礼仪中几乎有一种“非美国”的东西。我知道有人会不同意我的观点，但我认为对许多美国人来说，存在关于正确行为方式规则的想法——比单纯的常识更复杂的规则——似乎矫揉造作，是欧洲式的，就像是我们为争取自由而与英国人抗争的一样东西。并不是说我们粗鲁，我们只是不喜欢讲究。
The meantime, we're full of immigrants from much older, fancier countries. Nazanin Rafsanjani was born in Iran, grew up in Minnesota, and she's steeped in both worlds. She still has family in Iran she goes to see. She's got her family here. But then, American friends. She went to school here. Her husband is American. And she says there's one key Iranian concept that is way beyond even the most party manners American notion of please, thank you, and oh, you shouldn't have gone to all this trouble.
同时，我们这里到处都是来自更古老、更讲究国家的移民。纳扎宁·拉夫桑贾尼出生在伊朗，在明尼苏达州长大，她沉浸在两个世界中。她仍然有家人在伊朗，她会去探望。她在那里有她的家人。但还有，美国朋友。她在这里上学。她的丈夫是美国人。她说有一个核心的伊朗概念，远超美国人最派对式的“谢谢，请，哦，你本不必破费”的礼貌观念。
OK, so it's called tarof. And it's basically this social custom of never saying what you want and offering things to people that you may or may not really want to give them. What happens, like, millions of times a day in Iran, probably is that you-- you know, you go to someone's house and they say, "Are you hungry? What can I get you? Do you want some tea? Do you want some fruit? Cookies?" And you say, "No, no, no. I'm just here, I just want to see you. I'm not here for any of that stuff. I'm not hungry. I don't want any tea."
好了，它叫“塔罗夫”（Tarof）。它基本上是一种社交习俗，从不说出你想要什么，并向人们提供你可能想给，也可能不想给的东西。在伊朗每天发生数百万次的情况是，你走进某人家，他们会说：“你饿吗？我能给你拿点什么？你要喝茶吗？你要吃点水果吗？饼干？”你说，“不，不，不。我只是来看看你。我不是为了那些东西。我不饿。我不喝茶。”
And they're like, "No, you have to have some tea. You have to have some fruit. Just one orange. Just have an orange. Have an orange and an apple." So you may or may not want the tea, you may really want the tea. They may be on their way out the door and not expecting you, and not want you at all to stay for tea or fruit or anything, but it doesn't matter. They've come out of their kitchen with a giant bowl of fruit, which ever Iranian has. And you're like, "No, no, no, I don't want anything. I'm just here to talk for a second. Please, please, please. No, no." And there may be some physical altercation where they're like grabbing your hands as you try to put fruit on their plate. And what I see happen a lot is that the person who the food and tea is being forced on will take a sip of the tea, or peel the orange and eat a slice and leave the rest on their plate.
他们会说：“不，你必须喝点茶。你必须吃点水果。就一个橙子。吃个橙子吧。吃个橙子和一个苹果。”所以你可能想要喝茶，也可能真的想要茶。他们可能正要出门，根本不期待你，一点也不想让你留下来喝茶或吃水果什么的，但这无关紧要。他们已经从厨房里拿出一大碗水果，每个伊朗人家里都有。你会说：“不，不，不，我什么都不想要。我只是来谈谈。请，请，请。不，不。”可能还会发生一些肢体冲突，你试图把水果放在他们的盘子里时，他们会抓住你的手。我常看到的是，被迫接受食物和茶的人会喝一口茶，或者剥开橙子吃一片，把剩下的留在盘子里。
Because if you eat the orange, then they have to start tarofing again. You know what I mean? If you finish the orange or drink the tea, they're not going to just let your plate be empty.
因为如果你吃了橙子，他们就必须再次开始“塔罗夫”。你明白我的意思吗？如果你吃完了橙子或喝完了茶，他们是不会让你的盘子空着的。
What happens if they say, stay. Have some tea. You have to have some tea. And you say, great, I would love some tea?
如果他们说，留下来吧。喝点茶。你一定要喝点茶。而你说，太棒了，我很想喝点茶呢？
I don't know. I mean, that just never happens. I'm sure it does happen from time to time, but it just is so rare for someone to say, "Do you want some tea?" or, "Are you hungry?" and for the other Iranian to say, like, "Yes, sure." That's so embarrassing. That would be really embarrassing. It happens to me a lot.
我不知道。那从来没发生过。我相信它偶尔会发生，但一个伊朗人问“要喝茶吗？”或“你饿吗？”，另一个伊朗人回答“是的，当然”，太少见了。太尴尬了。那真的会很尴尬。这种情况我遇到过很多。
An uncomfortable thing that would often happen to me growing up is that I'd have all these American friends coming over to our house, and it always makes me slightly uncomfortable when someone's at my parents' house and they compliment my parents on something. Because the custom is, if you go to my parents' house and you say, like, "That's a beautiful painting on the wall," they'll offer it to you. They'll just be like, "Take it. It's yours. It's not good here anyway. It would look better in your house. Take it. It's not worth anything to us. It's much more important that you have it."
成长过程中经常发生的一件不舒服的事情是，我有所有这些美国朋友来我家，当有人在我父母家并且他们恭维我父母的东西时，我总是会感到稍微不舒服。因为习俗是，如果你去我父母家说，“墙上的画真漂亮”，他们会把它送给你。他们会直接说：“拿去吧。它是你的。放在这里也不好看。在你的房子里会更好看。拿去。这对我们来说不值什么。你拥有它更重要。”
Are people then overwhelmed? Like, oh, I didn't mean--
人们会不知所措吗？就像，哦，我不是那个意思——
Yes, exactly. Definitely yeah, it catches people off guard. People are like, no-- what? I'm not going to take your-- what? It's really confusing to somebody who doesn't know that they don't want you to take their picture on the wall. They just have to say that. You just have to say it.
是的，没错。绝对会，这让人措手不及。人们会想，不——什么？我不要拿你的——什么？对于不知道他们并不真的想让你拿走墙上照片的人来说，这真的很令人困惑。你只是必须那样说。你只是必须说出来。
It permeates every single-- like, for example, my parents were just visiting us. And I'd see Alex, my husband, doing this, where he'd pour them a glass of water and he'd say, "Do you want ice in the water?" And my mom would say, "No." But she wanted ice in the water. Like, I knew she wanted ice in the water. She knew she wanted ice in the water. But she'd say no, and so he wouldn't put it in the water. So then I would have to go and get the ice cubes and put it in her water.
它渗透到每一个方面——例如，我父母刚来看我们。我看到我的丈夫亚历克斯这样做，他给他们倒了一杯水，说：“你要在水里加冰吗？”我妈妈会说：“不。”但她其实想要冰块。就像，我知道她想要冰块。她也知道她想要冰块。但她会说不，所以他也就没放冰块。所以我必须去拿冰块放进她的水里。
It sounds tiring actually. It sounds--
听起来真累。听起来——
Yeah. I mean, when I describe it to people, it's really time consuming. Because it's not just-- this happens like in Iran, when you go into a store and you're going to buy-- I think we were buying dried fruit or something. And you take what you want up to the counter and you'll go to pay. And the store owner says, like, "It's worthless. This is worthless. You shouldn't even-- it's worthless to you. Your value is so much more than this thing that you're trying to buy." And and then you have to say, "No, no, no. Really, how much is it?" And then they say, "No, no, no. Just take it. Just take it. You shouldn't have to pay for it." And you're like, "No, no, no. Please, tell me how much it is." And then finally you get to a point where they are going to tell you the price. And then the funny thing that happens, that I've seen happen so many times, is like-- and then they quote you a price that's like way more than the thing is actually worth. So then you have to shift.
是的。当我和别人描述它时，它非常耗时。因为这不仅仅是——这发生在伊朗，当你走进一家店，你要买——我想我们是在买干果什么的。你把你想要的拿到柜台，准备结账。店主说：“它一文不值。这东西没价值。你甚至不应该——对你来说它没价值。你的价值远高于你试图买的这件东西。”然后你必须说：“不，不，不。真的，它多少钱？”然后他们说：“不，不，不。拿去吧。拿去吧。你不应该付钱。”你会说：“不，不，不。请告诉我它多少钱。”然后最后你到了他们要告诉你价格的地步。然后有趣的事情发生了，我见过很多次——他们给你报价，价格比这件东西实际价值高得多。然后你必须改变。
So it flips? It flips completely and becomes a bargaining session?
所以它反转了？它完全反转并变成了一场讨价还价的会议？
Exactly. Then it becomes the sort of like haggling, a haggling session.
没错。然后它变成了所谓的像讨价还价，一场讨价还价的会议。
So who's the person in your family who's best at this? Who's the expert?
那么你的家庭中谁最擅长这个？谁是专家？
In my family, I would say the expert is my great aunt. She will wear you down. You'll say no, and you'll really mean no. And you'll be like, no, I'm not hungry. And she just puts the food in front of you. To the point of like-- I don't know if this is going to translate. But I would like wake up in the middle of the night and see her in my room about to put like a blanket over me, even though I told her a million times like, I'm not hot. I don't get hot. Please don't put a blanket over me. And she would just come in in the middle of the night and throw a blanket over me. And a couple of times I would catch her. Be like, what are you doing? What are you doing in here? And then she reduces you. With the tarof thing, she literally reduces you to begging. You're like, please, don't do this. Please.
在我的家庭中，我会说专家是我的姑婆。她会让你妥协。你会说不，而且你真的不是那个意思。你会想，不，我不饿。但她只是把食物放在你面前。甚至到这样的地步——我不知道这能不能翻译。但我会在半夜醒来，看到她在我的房间里，正要把一条毯子盖在我身上，即使我告诉了她一百万遍，我不热。我不怕热。请不要给我盖毯子。她会在半夜走进来，往我身上扔一条毯子。我有几次会抓住她。会想，你在做什么？你在这里做什么？然后她让你屈服。通过“塔罗夫”，她真的让你变成了乞讨。你会说，请，不要这样做。求求你。
There's no way to shortcut it? There's no way to say, "I know what you're doing. You know, I know what you're doing. We know what we're doing. Let's just do the short version." You can't do that? Like, it has to play out?
没有捷径吗？没有办法说，“我知道你在做什么。你知道，我知道你在做什么。我们都知道我们在做什么。我们就来个简短版本吧。”你不能那样做吗？它必须演完？
Yeah. And I mean, you could cut to the chase and be like, stop tarofing. But that's kind of rude. Because then you're implying that the person is being fake.
是的。我是说，你可以直接切入主题说，别“塔罗夫”了。但这有点粗鲁。因为那样你就暗示对方是在装模作样。
Does it make it hard sometimes to even know what you want? Because you have to do all the responses, there are all these consequences no matter what you do. Does it make it hard to even understand, am I hungry? Am I not hungry? Do I want to stay here? Do I want this person here?
这有时会让你甚至不知道自己想要什么吗？因为你必须做出所有反应，无论你做什么都有所有这些后果。这会让你甚至难以理解，我饿吗？我不饿吗？我想留在这里吗？我想要这个人在这里吗？
I don't know if it makes it hard to know what you want. But I think what happens is that you end up not caring what you want. If you're like me, you just want the tarof to stop.
我不知道这是否让你难以知道自己想要什么。但我认为发生的是，你最终根本不在乎自己想要什么。如果你像我一样，你只是想让“塔罗夫”停止。
That becomes what you want.
那变成了你想要的。
Exactly. All you want is the tarofing to stop. That's all you want.
没错。你想要的只是“塔罗夫”停止。这就是你想要的全部。
Nazanin Rafsanjani works at the public radio program On the Media .
纳扎宁·拉夫桑贾尼在公共广播节目《媒体》（On the Media）工作。
Our last story is about the hardest kind of gift to give, one that requires sacrifice. Not just giving, but giving something up. It's a piece of short fiction by writer Etgar Keret. He's been on our show before. You'll remember him if you've heard one of his stories. They don't sound like anyone else's.
我们的最后一个故事是关于最难给出的那种礼物，需要牺牲的那种。不仅仅是给予，而是放弃某种东西。这是作家埃特加·凯雷特的一篇短篇小说。他以前上过我们的节目。如果你听过他的故事，你会记得他。它们听起来不像任何人的故事。
This one takes place in Israel where Etgar lives, and is read by actor Michael Chernus.
这个故事发生在埃特加居住的以色列，由演员迈克尔·切努斯朗读。
Yonatan had a brilliant idea for a documentary. He'd knock on doors. Just him, no camera crew, no nonsense, just Yonatan, alone, a little camera in his hand, asking, "If you found a talking goldfish that granted you three wishes, what of this goldfish would you wish?"
约纳坦有一个绝妙的纪录片构思。他会去敲门。只有他自己，没有摄像组，没有废话，只有约纳坦，一个人，手里拿着一个小摄像机，问：“如果你找到一条会说话的金鱼，它能满足你三个愿望，你会向这条金鱼许什么愿？”
Folks would give their answers and Yoni would edit them down. Make clips of the more surprising responses. Before every set of answers, you'd see the person standing stock still in the entrance to his house. Onto this shot, he'd superimpose the subject's name, his family situation, his monthly income, and maybe even the party he'd voted for in the last election. That, together with the wishes, and maybe he'd end up with some real social commentary. A testament to the massive rift between all our dreams and the often unpromising realities in which we live.
人们会给出他们的答案，尤尼会编辑这些答案。制作那些更令人惊讶的回应剪辑。在每组答案之前，你会看到那个人站在房门口一动不动。在这个镜头上，他会叠加主题的名字、家庭状况、月收入，甚至可能是他在上次选举中投票的政党。加上这些愿望，也许他最终会得到一些真正的社会评论。这证明了我们所有的梦想与我们生活在其中的、往往不尽如人意的现实之间存在巨大的裂痕。
It was genius, Yoni was sure. And if not, at least it was cheap. All he needed was a door to knock on and a heart beating on the other side. With a little decent footage, he was sure he'd be able to sell it to channel eight or Discovery in a flash, either as a film or as a bunch of vignettes, little cinematic corners each with that singular soul standing in a doorway followed by three killer wishes. Precious, every one.
尤尼确信这是天才的想法。如果不是，至少它很便宜。他只需要一扇可以敲的门，和门后跳动的心脏。有了不错的素材，他确信自己能很快把它卖给8频道或探索频道，无论是作为电影还是作为一堆片段，每个电影角落都有那个站在门口的独特灵魂，随后是三个杀手级的愿望。每一个都很珍贵。
Even better, maybe he'd cash out, package it with a slogan and sell it to a bank or cellular phone company. Maybe tag it with something like, "Different dreams, different wishes, one bank." Or, "The bank that makes dreams come true."
更好的是，也许他会套现，贴上口号卖给银行或手机公司。也许贴上类似这样的标签：“不同的梦想，不同的愿望，一家银行。”或者，“让梦想成真的银行。”
No prep, no plotting, natural as can be, Yoni grabbed his camera and went out knocking on doors.
没有准备，没有计划，尤尼自然而然地抓起摄像机，出去敲门。
In the first neighborhood, the kindly folk that took part generally requested the foreseeable things-- health, money, bigger apartments, either to shave off a couple of years or a couple of pounds. But there were also the powerful moments, the big truths. There was one drawn, wizened old lady that asked simply for a child. There was a cocky, broad-shouldered ladykiller who put out his cigarette and as if the camera wasn't there, wished he were a girl. "Just for a night," he added holding a single finger right up to the lens.
在第一个社区，参与其中的善良人们通常请求可以预见的东西——健康、金钱、更大的公寓，或是想年轻几岁、瘦几磅。但也有强大的时刻，伟大的真理。有一位干瘪、憔悴的老太太简单地要求要一个孩子。有一个傲慢、宽肩膀的妇女杀手掐灭了烟，好像摄像机不在场一样，希望自己是个女孩。“仅仅一个晚上，”他补充说，竖起一个手指对着镜头。
Yonatan knew if the project was going to have weight, he'd have to get to everyone. To the unemployed, to the ultra religious, to the Arabs and Ethiopians and American ex-pats. Maybe some beleaguered Arab man would stand in his doorway and, looking through Yonatan and his camera, looking out into nothingness, just pause for a minute, nod his head, and wish for peace. That would be something to see.
约纳坦知道如果这个项目要有分量，他必须接触到每个人。接触失业者、极端宗教信徒、阿拉伯人和埃塞俄比亚人以及美国外籍人士。也许某个饱受折磨的阿拉伯人会站在门口，透过约纳坦和他的摄像机，看向虚无，停顿片刻，点点头，许愿要和平。那将是值得一看的东西。
Sergei [? Garalik ?] doesn't much like strangers banging on his door. Less so is he amenable to it when those strangers are asking him questions. In Russia when Sergei was young, it happened plenty. The KGB felt right at home knocking on his door. His father had been a Zionist, which was pretty much an invitation for them to drop by any old time.
谢尔盖（[听不清的名字]）不太喜欢陌生人敲他的门。如果这些陌生人在问他问题，他更不乐意。在俄罗斯，当谢尔盖年轻时，这种情况发生过很多次。克格勃在敲他门时感到很自在。他的父亲曾是犹太复国主义者，这几乎是邀请他们随时来访。
When Sergei got to Israel and then moved to Jaffa, his family couldn't wrap their heads around it. They'd ask him, "What are you looking to find in a place like that? There's no one there but addicts and Arabs and pensioners." But what is most excellent about addicts and Arabs and pensioners is that they don't come around knocking on Sergei's door. Like that, Sergei can get his sleep and get up when it's still dark. He can take his little boat out into the sea and fish until he's done fishing, by himself, in silence. The way it should be. The way it was.
当谢尔盖来到以色列，然后搬到雅法时，他的家人无法理解。他们会问他：“你在那样的地方能找到什么？那里除了瘾君子、阿拉伯人和养老金领取者外，什么都没有。”但瘾君子、阿拉伯人和养老金领取者最棒的地方是，他们不会来敲谢尔盖的门。这样，谢尔盖可以睡觉，天还没亮就起床。他可以开着小船出海，独自一人、安静地钓鱼，直到他钓完。就像它应该的那样。就像它曾经那样。
Until one day some kid with an earring in his ear-- looking a little bit homosexual-- comes knocking. Hard like that, rapping at his door, just the way Sergei doesn't like. And he says, this kid, that he has some questions he wants to put on the TV. Sergei tells the boy, tells him in what he thinks is a straightforward manner, that he doesn't want it. Not interested. Sergei gives the camera a shove to help make it clearer. But the earring boy is stubborn. He says all kinds of things, fast things, and it's a bit hard for Sergei to follow. His Hebrew isn't so good. The boy slows it down. Tells Sergei he's got a strong face, a nice face, and that he simply have to have him for this movie picture.
直到有一天，有个耳朵上戴着耳环的孩子——看起来有点同性恋倾向——来敲门。敲得很大声，就像谢尔盖不喜欢的那样。他那个孩子说，他有一些问题想放到电视上。谢尔盖告诉那个男孩，用他认为是直接的方式告诉他，他不感兴趣。谢尔盖推了一下摄像机以表达得更清楚。但那个戴耳环的男孩很顽固。他说了各种各样的事情，很快的事情，谢尔盖很难跟上。他的希伯来语不太好。男孩放慢了速度。告诉谢尔盖他有一张很有力的脸，一张漂亮的脸，他必须为这部电影找他。
Sergei can also slow down. He can also make clear. He tells the kid to [BLEEP] off. But the kid is slippery, and somehow between saying no and pushing the door closed, Sergei finds that the kid is in his house. He's already making his movie, running his camera without any permission. And from behind the camera, still telling Sergei about his face. That it's full of feeling. That it's tender.
谢尔盖也可以慢下来。他也可以表达清楚。他叫那个孩子滚开。但那个孩子很滑头，不知怎么地，在说“不”和关门之间，谢尔盖发现那个孩子已经在他的屋子里了。他已经在拍电影了，未经任何许可就在运行他的摄像机。并且在摄像机后面，还在跟谢尔盖说他的脸。说它充满了情感。说它很温柔。
Suddenly the kid spots Sergei's goldfish flitting around in its big glass jar in his kitchen. The kid with the earring starts screaming goldfish, goldfish. He's so excited. And this, this really pressures Sergei, who tells the kid, "It's nothing. Just a regular goldfish. Stop filming it. Just a goldfish," Sergei tells him. Just something he found flapping around in the net, a deep sea goldfish.
突然，那个孩子看到了谢尔盖的金鱼在他的厨房大玻璃罐里游来游去。那个戴耳环的孩子开始尖叫，金鱼，金鱼。他太兴奋了。这，这真的给了谢尔盖压力，他告诉那个孩子，“没什么。只是一条普通的金鱼。别拍它了。只是一条金鱼，”谢尔盖告诉他。只是他在网里发现的某种东西，一条深海金鱼。
But the boy isn't listening. He's still filming, and getting closer, and saying something about talking and fish and a magic wish. Sergei doesn't like this. Doesn't like that the boy is almost at it, already reaching for the jar.
但那个男孩没在听。他还在拍，越靠越近，说着什么关于说话、鱼和魔法愿望的事情。谢尔盖不喜欢这样。不喜欢那个男孩几乎到了它面前，已经伸手去拿罐子了。
In this instance, Sergei understands the boy didn't come for television. What he came for specifically is to snatch Sergei's fish, to steal it away.
在这种情况下，谢尔盖明白那个男孩不是为了电视而来。他专门来是为了抢走谢尔盖的鱼，把它偷走。
Before the mind of Sergei [? Garalik ?] really understands what it is his body has done, he seems to have taken the burner off the stove and hit the boy in the head. The boy falls. The camera falls with him. The camera breaks open on the floor, along with the boy's skull. There's a lot of blood coming out of that head. And Sergei really doesn't know what to do.
在谢尔盖（[听不清的名字]）的头脑真正理解他的身体做了什么之前，他似乎已经拿起了炉子上的燃烧器，击中了那个男孩的头。男孩倒下了。摄像机也跟着他一起倒下。摄像机在地板上破碎，男孩的头骨也破碎了。头里流出了很多血。谢尔盖真的不知道该怎么办。
That is, he knows exactly what to do, but it really would complicate things. Because if he brings this kid to the hospital, people are going to ask what happened. And it would take things in a direction Sergei doesn't want to go.
也就是说，他完全知道该做什么，但这真的会使事情复杂化。因为如果他把这个孩子送到医院，人们会问发生了什么。这会把事情引向谢尔盖不想走的方向。
"No reason to take him to the hospital anyway," says the goldfish in Russian. "That one's already dead."
“反正没理由带他去医院，”那条金鱼用俄语说。“那个已经死了。”
"He can't be dead," Sergei says with a moan. "I barely popped him. It's only a burner, only a little thing." Sergei holds it up to the fish, taps it against his own skull to prove it. It's not even that hard.
“他不可能死了，”谢尔盖呻吟着说。“我只是稍微砰了一下。那只是个燃烧器，只是个小玩意。”谢尔盖把它举向鱼，在自己的头骨上敲了一下证明。它甚至没那么硬。
"Maybe not," says the fish. "But apparently, it's harder than that kid's head."
“也许不是，”鱼说。“但显然，它比那个孩子的头更硬。”
"He wanted to take you from me," Sergei says almost crying.
“他想把你从我身边抢走，”谢尔盖几乎要哭着说。
"Nonsense," the fish says. "He was only here to make a little nothing for TV."
“胡说，”鱼说。“他只是为了给电视做个小玩意。”
"But he said--"
“但他说了——”
"He said," says the fish interrupting, "exactly what he was doing but you didn't get it. Honestly, your Hebrew, it's terrible."
“他说了，”鱼打断道，“完全是他正在做的，但你没明白。老实说，你的希伯来语太烂了。”
"Yours is better?" Sergei says. "Yours is so great?"
“你的更好吗？”谢尔盖说。“你的那么棒？”
"Yes, mine's super great," the goldfish says, sounding impatient. "I'm a magic fish. I'm fluent in everything."
“是的，我的超级棒，”金鱼说，声音显得不耐烦。“我是条魔法鱼。我精通一切。”
All the while, the puddle of blood from the earring kid's head is getting bigger and bigger, and Sergei is on his toes up against the kitchen wall desperate not to step in it, to get blood on his feet.
与此同时，耳环孩子头上流出的血坑变得越来越大，谢尔盖踮着脚尖靠在厨房墙上，绝望地不想踩在里面，不想让血弄到他的脚上。
"You do have one wish left," the fish reminds Sergei. He says it easy like that, as if Sergei doesn't know. As is either of them ever loses count.
“你确实还剩下一个愿望，”鱼提醒谢尔盖。他说的那么轻松，好像谢尔盖不知道一样。好像他们中的任何一个会数不清愿望一样。
"No," Sergei says. He's shaking his head from side to side. "I can't," he says. "I've been saving it. Saving it for something."
“不，”谢尔盖说。他左右摇着头。“我不能，”他说。“我一直把它留着。留着做点什么。”
"For what?" the fish says. But Sergei won't answer.
“为了什么？”鱼说。但谢尔盖不回答。
That first wish Sergei used when they discovered a cancer in his sister. A lung cancer. The kind you don't get better from. The fish undid it in an instant, the words barely out of Sergei's mouth. The second wish Sergei used up five years before on Svetia's boy. The kid was still small then, barely three, but the doctors already knew something in her son's head wasn't right. He was going to grow big, but not in the brain. Three was about as smart as he'd get. Svetia cried to Sergei in bed all night. Sergei walked home along the beach when the sun came up and he called to the fish, asked the goldfish to fix it as soon as he'd crossed through the door. He never told Svetia. And a few months later she left him for some cop, a Moroccan with a shiny Honda.
当他们发现他姐姐得了癌症时，谢尔盖用了第一个愿望。肺癌。那种你不会好转的癌症。鱼立刻把它撤销了，话刚从谢尔盖嘴里出来。谢尔盖在五年前为了斯维蒂亚的孩子用了第二个愿望。那个孩子当时还小，才三岁，但医生们已经知道她儿子头里的东西不对劲。他会长大，但脑子长不大。三岁大概就是他能达到的智力上限。斯维蒂亚整晚在床上向谢尔盖哭。太阳升起时，谢尔盖沿着海滩走回家，他呼唤那条鱼，要求金鱼在他跨进门的那一刻修复它。他从未告诉过斯维蒂亚。几个月后，她为了一个警察离开了他，一个开着闪亮本田的摩洛哥人。
In his heart, Sergei kept telling himself it wasn't for Svetia that he'd done it. That he'd wished his wish purely the boy. In his mind, he was less sure. And all kinds of thoughts about other things he could have done with that wish continued to gnaw at him, half driving him mad.
在心里，谢尔盖一直告诉自己，他这样做并不是为了斯维蒂亚。他纯粹是为了那个孩子。在心里，他不太确定。关于那个愿望他本可以做的其他事情的各种想法继续折磨着他，让他几乎发疯。
The third wish, Sergei hadn't yet wished for.
第三个愿望，谢尔盖还没许。
"I can restore him," says the gold fish. "I can bring him back to life."
“我可以让他恢复，”金鱼说。“我可以让他起死回生。”
"No one's asking," Sergei says.
“没人要求，”谢尔盖说。
"I can bring him back to the moment before," the goldfish says. "To before he knocks on your door. I can put him back to right there. I can do it. All you need to do is ask."
“我可以让他回到那一刻之前，”金鱼说。“回到他敲你门之前。我可以把他送回那里。我可以做到。你只需要问。”
"To wish my wish," Sergei says. "My last."
“许我的愿望，”谢尔盖说。“我的最后一个。”
The fish swishes his tail back and forth in the water, the way he does, Sergei knows, when he's truly excited. The goldfish can already taste freedom. Sergei can see it on him.
那条鱼在水里来回摆动尾巴，他知道，当它真正兴奋时会这样做。金鱼已经尝到了自由的滋味。谢尔盖能看出来。
After the last wish, Sergei won't have a choice. He'll have to let the goldfish go. His magic goldfish. His friend.
最后一个愿望之后，谢尔盖将别无选择。他必须放走金鱼。他的魔法金鱼。他的朋友。
"It's fixable," Sergei says. "I'll just mop up the blood. A good sponge and it will be like it never was."
“是可以修复的，”谢尔盖说。“我会把血擦干净。用一块好海绵，它会像从未发生过一样。”
That tail just goes back and forth. The fish's head steady. Sergei takes a deep breath. He steps out into the middle of the kitchen, out into that puddle.
那条尾巴只是来回摆动。鱼头很稳。谢尔盖深吸了一口气。他走到厨房中央，走到那个血坑里。
"When I'm fishing, while it's dark and the world's asleep," he says, half to himself and half to the fish. "I'll tie the kid to a rock and dump him in the sea. Not a chance, not in a million years will anyone ever find him."
“当我在钓鱼时，当世界在沉睡时，”他说，一半是对自己说，一半是对鱼说。“我会把孩子绑在一块石头上，扔进海里。绝无可能，一百万年里也不会有人发现他。”
"You killed him, Sergei, the goldfish says. "You murdered someone. But you're not a murderer." The goldfish stops swishing his tail. "If on this you won't waste a wish, then tell me, Sergei, what is it good for?"
“你杀了他，谢尔盖，”金鱼说。“你谋杀了某人。但你不是一个杀人犯。”金鱼停止了摆动尾巴。“如果在这件事上你不愿浪费一个愿望，那么告诉我，谢尔盖，它有什么用？”
It was in Bethlehem, actually, that Yonatan found his Arab, a handsome man who used his first wish for peace. His name was Munir. He was fat with a big white mustache. Super photogenic. It was moving the way he said it. Perfect, the way in which Munir wished his wish. Yoni knew right while he was filming that this guy would be his promo for sure.
其实是在伯利恒，约纳坦找到了他的阿拉伯人，一个用第一个愿望祈求和平的英俊男人。他的名字叫穆尼尔。他很胖，留着大白胡子。超级上镜。穆尼尔许愿的方式很感人。尤尼在拍摄时就知道这家伙肯定是他的预告片明星。
Either him or that Russian. The one that looked straight into the camera and said if he ever found a talking goldfish, he wouldn't ask of it a single thing. He'd just stick it on a shelf in a big glass jar and talk to him all day. Didn't matter about what. Maybe sports, maybe politics. Whatever a goldfish was interested in chatting about. Anything, the Russian said, not to be alone.
要么是他，要么是那个俄罗斯人。那个直视镜头说如果他找到一条会说话的金鱼，他什么都不会要求的人。他只会把它放在大玻璃罐的架子上，整天跟它聊天。聊什么都无所谓。也许是体育，也许是政治。随便什么金鱼感兴趣聊的话题。什么都行，那个俄罗斯人说，只要不孤单。
Etgar Keret's newest book in English is called The Girl on the Fridge and Other Stories . This story was translated by Nathan Englander.
埃特加·凯雷特最新的英文书叫《冰箱上的女孩及其他故事》。这个故事由内森·英格兰德翻译。
Today, while Ira was in Georgia, our program was produced by Jane Feltes with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sara Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Eric Mennel.
今天，当艾拉在佐治亚州时，我们的节目由简·费尔特斯制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩和艾丽莎·希普参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。埃里克·门内尔提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Management oversight for our show by our boss, Torey Malatia, and editorial oversight by our other boss, Ira Glass, a man who is scrupulous about staying well-hydrated, but somehow is also tragically conflicted about it.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的管理监督人是我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚，编辑监督人是我们另一位老板艾拉·格拉斯，一个对保持水分充足非常谨慎，但不知何故又对此感到悲剧性矛盾的男人。
I don't want a drink. But I need a drink. I need a drink! Now!
我不想喝酒。但我需要喝酒。我需要喝酒！现在！
More stories from This American Life next week, like we always do about this time.
下周会有更多来自《美国生活》的故事，就像我们每周这个时候一样。
PRI. Public Radio International
PRI。国际公共广播电台